what's going on everyone axel beats here
for anime uproar and today we are diving
into the demon slayer story to talk all
about the shape-shifting demon king of
pops many different forms
there's quite a few of them and
definitely some come across as much
cooler than others but we are going to
be talking about every single one of
them here if you enjoy these closer
looks at demon slayer characters as well
as their forms and stories remember to
hit that like button and let us know you
want to see more and you can also
subscribe to the channel if you're new
so that you don't miss any future demon
slayer videos if you're looking for
videos similar to this one after you can
also check out our video on all of
tonjiro's forums from the other day or
my own video on character design in
demon slayer over on my own channel with
all that being said though this intro
has gone on long enough so let's get
into it spoilers and all muzon being the
immortal shape-shifting demon he is
tends to change his appearance at the
drop of a hat however he obviously
didn't start as this monstrous
powerhouse rather muzon's first form was
human
and his story begins as meekly as
possible we don't really know the exact
year that he was born but we do know
that it takes place in the heian period
about a thousand years ago and during
this period muzon was already struggling
for life even before he was born his
heart had stopped several times while in
utero and by the time he was actually
born he was pronounced stillborn his
body would be taken to be cremated but
moments before being turned to ash
muzon's heart began again and he let out
his first cry however even after defying
death so many times his survival would
not be assured and most of his human
life was spent riddled with illness
and perhaps naturally for someone in his
position he developed a severe fear of
both illness and of death unfortunately
for him though he would be diagnosed
with a disease that would ultimately
lead to his death before he even reached
20. something which is pretty
interesting to note when you consider
that the demon slayers who would take
him down would mostly awaken their demon
slayer marks and die before reaching 25
back to muzon though not all was
hopeless a doctor suggested there might
be something he could do and began
testing experimental new medicine on him
muzon became enraged when he saw no
progress though and killed the doctor
thinking that the medicine had been a
failure
but in reality it had worked muzon's
body became powerful but at the cost of
him needing to eat human flesh in order
to survive something he was more than
willing to do and this brings us to
muzon's second form and the start of his
demon life before we get into that
though we do learn that muzon becoming a
demon was the trigger for the ubu
yashiki family to becoming cursed and to
be as frail and ill as he was
each member being destined to die young
and have their bodies become more and
more weak as they age in trying to
escape his own fate we see him passing
his maladies onto the future generations
running from his own problems only to
make them other peoples down the line
and this method of passing the buck onto
other people or of putting himself in
good situations at the cost of other
people's lives is something we see being
followed through thematically for the
entirety of his time as a demon as a
demon muzon needed to stay out of the
sunlight or he would be instantly burned
away the sun would become a reminder of
escaping cremation as an infant to
overcome this muzon would have two
options firstly he could find the blue
spider lily this would be the final part
of his treatment that the doctor would
have given him had he not been killed
but now it was out of his reach as it
only bloomed during the daytime for a
few days of the year making it something
that both he and demons under him would
never be able to attain his second
option is that he could absorb another
demon who was immune to sunlight like
nezuko would eventually be revealed to
be to attain these goals muzon would go
on to create hundreds of other demons in
hope of either creating this sun immune
demon or that one of them might find the
spider lily for him again muzon only has
to eat people he doesn't have to turn
them into demons but he's willing to
ruin their lives and corrupt them to
make his own life better on top of this
we almost never see muzon searching for
the blue spider lily himself instead he
will tend to use other demons to solve
his problems for him just as he pushed
his problems onto the ubishiki clan and
while we're on the subject of the blue
spider lily just a quick side note here
the blue spider lily is a purely
mythical flower
but the red spider lily is both very
real and extremely prominent in japanese
mythos
specifically it grows along the sanzu
river and is meant to guide the dead
towards their reincarnation and their
next lives we even see it showing up
when zenitsu defeats kaigaku and then
sees jigiro at the border between the
living and the dead so if the red spider
lily is a symbol of accepting your own
death and moving on to the next life
then the blue spider lily could be a
symbol of avoiding death and clinging to
life just a cool bit of symbolism that i
wanted to include here while becoming
accustomed to this new demon body muzon
gained incredible confidence in himself
as long as he stayed out of the sun he
was untouchable and no human could ever
oppose him he was finally free from his
fear of death at least that's how it
seemed eventually though he crossed
paths with yurichi the first breath of
the sun user
and while muzon had come across several
demon slayers in the past none of them
were a real threat he challenged
yurichi's smugly thinking that it would
be an easy match but yorici quickly
overpowered him bringing him down and
backing him into a wall until muzon was
forced to blow himself up scattering his
body into hundreds of pieces but even so
yurichi managed to destroy even these
fragments missing only a very small
portion of them but even this was enough
for muzon to regenerate from despite
making it out alive muzon would spend
the rest of yurichi's life hiding
himself away and began working from the
shadows and having other demons act in
his set to avoid putting his own life in
danger just in case another yurichi
would ever show up anyways muzon takes
on several different forms throughout
his life as a demon however it seems
like he does prefer his normal adult
male form as he always comes back to it
and anytime we see him in the past he is
always in this form this is the form
that we see him in when he first meets
tonjiro the king of pop form if you will
which looks like a 20 to 30 year old man
again we see him looking like this when
he first meets akaza when he first meets
kokushibo and when he battled with
yurichi in just about every flashback
any demons have of him and permanently
after the entertainment district arc
until he goes for a more large-scale
transformation it seems to be his go-to
form and as we see in each of his forms
muzon's body is always meant to make the
most of each situation that he finds
himself in to get the biggest benefit or
to hold the highest status the king of
pop form even sees him having a human
family which allows him to blend into
his environment and keep him from being
targeted by demon slayers as they say
the best place to hide is often in plain
sight we also see him taking this form
when visiting doki and it's hard to tell
if doki is just filled with adoration
for muzon in general or if she's
extremely attracted to him but one of
these is definitely true and while we do
see many demons sucking up to him
throughout the series it's typically out
of fear of being killed and rarely do we
see them making this kind of face
of course while muzon is physically
strong he still has a very sickly white
tone to him we see someone commenting on
this after he meets tanjiro and moves on
killing that person as a result while he
is effectively healthy now he is still
drastically fearful of death and of
illness and he hates to be associated
with either of those traits which leads
us into his next actual appearance in
the series and his next form while we do
see muzon in a few memories or
flashbacks after this point he doesn't
actually appear in the flesh until after
rui's death where he gathers all the
remaining lower moons together to be
slaughtered here he appears in his
milfsan form he's not in this for very
long so there isn't much to actually
talk about in terms of what he does but
i do at least have an idea of why this
form was selected we know that this
isn't a very common form for muzon as
even the lower moons initially don't
recognize him and we know that there's
always a purpose behind his actions
so what was the purpose behind becoming
a woman well as i mentioned this is his
next appearance in the series after
being called very pale and freaking out
about it and while man being pale in
japan might be a sign of either weakness
or illness for a woman pale skin was
considered to be very beautiful
specifically something which picked up
in popularity in the heian period which
again muzon was born in so i believe
that to avoid looking weak and to fit
what his version of an ideal person
might be at the time as well as to
soothe his insecurities he decided to be
a woman here after this we see muzon
taking the form of a young child as
muzon has always seemed to have a pretty
significant lust for knowledge because
he wants to find a cure for his son
weakness he appears to be a prodigy as a
child this does a few things for him
firstly it strokes his ego he's still
not mentally at a hundred percent he's
having a rough time of things and
constantly being called a genius will do
a lot for a guy secondly it allows him
to be adopted by an affluent family
which gave him high social standing as
well as access to both comfortable
living and any excess money he might
need finally being a child has some
level of innate security for him because
one
it's pretty good camouflage and two
if he was ever to be attacked everyone
around him would likely step in to
protect him and saying that kid is a
demon probably wouldn't get a demon
slayer very far with the public
again this form is just another way for
muzon to take advantage of those around
him and put himself in the most
advantageous position possible as soon
as he's set up with the time and
resources that he needed he reverts back
to his normal form for the rest of the
series that is until the final battle
muzon arrives to kill oyakata but he's
lured into a trap in doing so the
mansion explodes injuring muzon and
scaring him quite a bit but he's able to
relax himself knowing he'll be able to
recover over time however as he regains
his calm tamayo pierces him with a
series of blood demon spikes and
immobilizes him before plunging her fist
and the drug she made for him into his
stomach warning him that this drug would
eventually turn him human
the slayers arrive to finish him off but
everyone is brought into the infinity
castle and muzon is instead given time
to recover he wraps himself up in a
cocoon-lex structure within the castle
where he can buy his time and when he
emerges he is in a totally different
form he has long white-haired demonic
mouths all over his body and
tendril-like whips coming out of his
back which is decidedly less looking in
this form he easily takes care of all
the lower ranked demon slayers in the
area killing and devouring them to heal
himself before finally finishing off
tomo then the real battle begins the
hashira tanjiro khanau genya
and inosuke just finished off all of the
remaining upper moons but not without
heavy losses genya shinobu and muichiro
have all died and those who are alive
are looking far worse for wear slowly
the remaining demon slayers arrive to
the battlefield and muzon is demolishing
them even taking one of tonjiro's eyes
before poisoning him and leaving him
unconscious it isn't just tanjiru though
he is swatting off the other demon
slayers like they are less than flies
once all of the demon slayers have
assembled the group manages to push back
here and there but ultimately it comes
down to him being an immortal and having
infinite chances to strike back while
the demon slayers can barely afford to
be hit once without risking terrible
poisoning or worse and on top of this
they have to hold him off until sunrise
so things are looking pretty bleak
however tonjiro wakes up here and makes
his way back onto the battlefield having
just peered into ancestral memories and
learning the secrets of the 13th form of
sun breathing with this at his disposal
he can fight back but it takes all he
can do just to keep breathing while he
performs his attack muzon begins
recognizing that tanjiro is a threat but
says he's nothing compared to yorichi
but even so muzon is struggling for some
reason panicking he looks back into
tomio's memories to see what else the
drug might have done not only was the
drug meant to turn him human but it was
also causing him to age extremely fast
and over the course of the battle he had
already aged 9 000 years
which is why his hair hadn't returned to
being black he was slowing down and
that's why the slayers were starting to
get the upper hand we learn later that
the drug also prevents him from bursting
into thousands of fragments and escaping
that way as well and with all of those
parts in play the slayers can begin
their counter-attack scars begin
emerging all over muzon's body as it
can't keep up with its rapid
regeneration and they reveal where
yurichi cut him years and years ago this
shows the demon slayers where muzon's
vital organs were and marks the weak
points for them to attack with their red
blades
ultimately through a massive group
effort the odds fall in the demon
slayer's hands and they manage to corner
muzon as the sun rises in one final
gambit muzon creates a shell of flesh in
the form of a giant baby around his body
in hopes of protecting himself from the
sun long enough for him to escape but
it's no use the demon slayers manage to
hold him down and finally he is defeated
now it's a pretty direct parallel but i
know that a lot of people really don't
like the demon baby form so much so i'm
going to explain it anyways muzon was a
coward who relied on others for
protection he was nothing more than a
giant baby the entire series who would
put up walls and facades to hide himself
away while yes it does look admittedly
lame as hell
it's also incredibly fitting for a
monster who avoided cremation as a
stillborn to be burnt up in the sun as
he revealed himself to still be that
baby now that said muzon's story
technically doesn't end there the poison
he left within tonjiro actually had a
small bit of himself within it just
enough to cling on to the living cells
left within tonjiro's body and bring him
back to life as the inheritor of muzon's
will in the ultimate demon form but
while his will is being passed on this
isn't technically muzon himself
so if you want to learn more about that
form you'll have to check out our video
all about tanjiro's forms after this one
muzon really is an interesting demon
he's this cowardly mastermind pulling
the strings of others on his own quest
for immortality despite that he has this
overwhelming presence when he actually
shows up it kind of feels like you have
this superman-esque figure with next to
no weaknesses and incredible power
but even so he's still terrified at
every corner it's a pretty unique
duality and whether or not it works is
kind of up for debate but at the very
least i think it makes for a good
discussion piece
so let me know what you think about him
down in the comments do you like muzon
do you dislike muzon did you find
yourself oddly attracted to milf son
i want to know everything you have to
say down below for now though if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more demon slayer content remember to
leave a like to let us know and if
you're new to anime uproar or you just
want to stay up to date with all of our
videos be sure to hit that subscribe
button and ring the bell to select all
notifications finally you can also
follow us over on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar or you can follow myself
at excellionyt with all that being said
though i hope you enjoyed this deep dive
into muzan's forums and until next time
remember to stay excellent